- Ce local vide en face du métro
Outremont va le rester encore
populaires.
- Une pétition de
de résidents d'Outremont.
- Qui s'inquiétaient de voir
Québécoise du Cannabis ouvrir
ses portes. Trop près, selrès, n
eux, des écoles du quartier,
même si la distance
par la loi était respectée.
Ils réclamaient que
l'arrondissement SQDC.
- Ça soutient les valeurs
familiales du quartier.
- Si c'est pour la sécurité
nts, bien, ça serait
une bonne idée.
résidente d'Outremont
s peut-être passée par
là aussi, mais il y a plein
Je pense que c'est pas
le meilleur endroit pour met
une SQDC.
- L'argument de la prévention,te
dans le secteur depuis plus
d'une dizaine d'année,
il est contestable.
résidente d'Outremont- Ce que- e
vivant sur l'avenue Van Horne,
juste en face du collège Stan,ve
toutes les couleurs avecces pet,
SQDC ou pas dans le quartier,
ça changera pas grand-chose
- Il y a aussi, derrière,
une réflexion sur l'impact
en termes de qualité de vie.
Car Outr
un arrondissement sans bar,
sans SAQ et donc sans vente
de cannabis pour l'instant.
- S'ils ouvrent une SQDC ici,
peut-ê vont ouvrir
des bars. Je sais pas, peut-être
que le quartier va changer.
- Allô, on habite à Montréal!
st comme pst comme pst comme pss
un petit peu intouchable.
- L'arrondissement a tranché :
pas de prohibition, mais
rrement des critères.
Le bail a été annulé et cela
réduit fortement la zone où
pourrait s'ouvrir une SQDC.
Pour cette spécialiste en
éthique et politiques de santé
publique, ces ajustements
peuvent avoir des conséquences.
EMMANUELLE MARCEAU, prof. assoc.
École de santé publique, UdeM
- Alors on peut même se poser
la question, est-ce
qu'éventuellement, ça va pas
entraîner d'autres quartiers
à faire de même puis
éventuellement, le gouvernement,
à revoir sa norme, si
effectivement, on se rend compte
qu'elle correspond moins
au désir des citoyens
puis peut-être à des enjeux
de santé publique.
- Outremont n'est pas le seul
endroit où la SQDC a eu
des bâtons dans les roues.
Autres déboires à Saint-Léonard,
où la vente est totalement
interdite depuis 2019.
DOMINIC PERRI, conseiller
municipal, Saint-Léonard
- Les parents ont été
très contents, parce que c'est
un moyen de justement, de ne pas
banaliser cette substance.
en justice
contre l'arrondissement
ne sera engagée par la SQDC.
Verdun, Lachine et le Sud-Ouest
ont tous dit non à un certain
moment à une succursale, tandis
qu'Anjou a fortement restreint
la zone d'implantation possible.
- Oui, on peut se poser
des questions à savoir si on va
pas tomber sur une santé
publique à la pièce qui va être
à géométrie variable.
- Mêmes divisions dans
l'arrondissement Villeray-Saint-
Michel-Parc-Extension
où une succursale s'apprête
à ouvrir au métro Jarry.
Une station de transit pour
les jeunes de l'École secondaire
George-Vanier, située à environ
500 mètres de là.
- On incite les je
consommer. Quand tu les ouvres
tout près, c'est une tentation.
- Beaucoup de gens sont d'accord
pour dire qu'il faut évoluer.
un peu dans nos mentalités.
- L'arrondissement assure
n'avoir reçu aucune plainte
citoyenne. La SQDC précise
n'avoir subi une annulation
de bail qu'à trois reprises
à Montréal et que c'est la
première fois que cela survient
à la suite de pressions
citoyennes.
Ici Mathieu Prost,
Radio Canada, Mon